toujours en côte d'or mais précisément
dans le val de saône cette fois la
nouvelle vie d'un ancien centre de
stockage de déchets un site qui
accueille désormais une centrale solaire
a light est inaugurée aujourd'hui sur
les communes de pontailler sur saône et
drambon un parc qui va alimenter près
d'un tiers de la population de ce canton
présentation avec elle a besoin et
gabrielle talon au beau milieu du val de
saône en pleine nature des milliers de
panneaux photovoltaïques
voici la nouvelle centrale solaire de
côte-d'or
quand on est arrivé donc le site était
déjà quasiment dans cet état donc on est
sur un ancien site de stockage de
déchets qui a été réhabilitée donc pour
cette partie en 2003 et pour les parties
suivantes un peu plus tard en 2008
jocelyn fâche phare supervise le
chantier depuis un an
le site a été choisi pour son
ensoleillement et son plateau uniforme
idéal pour installer tous ces panneaux
la centrale elle fait 12 mégawatts sur
20 hectares
donc effectivement en taille de
centrales c'est déjà assez conséquent
déranger infinie de miroirs géants un
enchevêtrement de capteurs on a opté ici
pour la technologie dite cristalline
nous avons une technologie classique de
panneaux cristallins qui utilise donc le
rayonnement solaire pour produire de
l'énergie courant continu dans un
premier temps qui a ensuite transformé
par un poste de transformation en cours
en moyenne tension 20000 volts injecté
ensuite sur le réseau de distribution
depuis décembre tout fonctionne pour
alimenter quatre mille cinq cents foyers
les communes de drambon et pontailler
sur saône veulent faire de ce projet une
vitrine de leur modernisation
les élus ont flairé le potentiel ça a
apporté à la commune d art d emploi
puisque jeudi le site emploie 30
personnes actuellement
c'est un investissement direct de
plusieurs millions d'euros pour les
panneaux photovoltaïques
et puis les entreprises locales qui
participent
un projet qui profite à l'économie et ça
va continuer une extension du parc est
prévu d'ici deux à trois ans